she glamour does not want to know about
your bunions so you want to hit a
jewelry store
not exactly a diamond mine yes it's
exactly right or what the met how does
it feel to be a part of not only a huge
iconic franchise but a film centered
around so many badass women especially
in the current Hollywood climate it
doesn't happen very often but I think
you know it's gonna happen more and more
it is certainly we just talked about
Thelma and Louise I mean it's been
amazing films you know made by directed
by men often written by men with women
at the center and I think what's
beginning to change you're having a lot
more female directors which is really
exciting it's just it's better for
everybody
diversity is a good thing I'm getting
that t-shirt I know you obviously hang
around with what's the famous people all
the time but was there even you were a
little star-struck
you have to pinch yourself I would have
liked to have been on the carpet when
common was there oh nice I was like what
didn't come and do an IJ away no one I
don't see a mom I didn't even get near
the cupboard Mindy and I was like oh
yeah oh so I didn't see any famous
people not even either but I didn't do
anything on the carpet I didn't have any
glue I did why was it where it was
common when I was oh yeah he's really a
tall drink of water to say I think maybe
they kept you probably probably no no he
knew she's keys people said she might
just think
I mean you all have so much fun while
filming whether any standout hilarious
moments that you'll never forget we're
never on camera there was one very funny
time where this one had a tiny beat
which doesn't happen often where she was
had no idea that her line was okay yeah
it was very late night and it happened a
couple of times and I clearly on
sentiment yeah but I didn't call you
times and we when she did come to the
way she came back it was really like
like with intentionality we were really
yes because she was rehearsing a play
but it was sixteen point five million
dollars in each of your bank accounts
five weeks from now that's a lot any of
you other characters who would it be and
why to take him on yeah I would yeah I
would pick Debbie just cuz I'd like to
be the one I have been thinking about
doing this for five years and guess what
I knew that nobody would ask me to do it
cuz I think you would be fabulous doing
Annie's role yes you would agree they're
all amazing amazing Oh diva actor
oh okay I just want solidarity and I
haven't yet okay everybody let's get
started
can we go count you down three two
came on
[Music]
you